this is enemy at the gate and not to be
confused with the movie the the classic
awesome incredibly not true movie you
couldn't figure that out you deserve to
be happy about Hoskins playing a Russian
you Leo I he was the most authentic
Russian I've ever seen since we got cat
what is it going on Korra's returning
bones opening up about general zelda
generals Isengard has marched and by
yeah as soon as this giant army is in
front of like you know the same of the
earth Kingdom I was really you will and
just kind of a stalemate right now
they're just waiting to see who's gonna
make the first move and corner goes in
to try and negotiate generals Elvis says
alright I will hold off the attack if
you can talk to the the current owner of
that Kingdom but it turns out they're
gonna do their own attack it looks like
it's gonna most likely fuck everything
up if Zelda's not already planning
something which he proudly already is
and Varrick and Zhu Li have a lot of
time in this one which is great and Mei
is sick and the promise tonight Julie
apparently is going back to going back
to general so that is the most I think
obvious like she's just gonna be a mole
ya know that that's my thought too I
like how they set it up with her it
would be holy or so we're totally wrong
Bard's do that thing not the thing um
but I like how they set it up in them
like he has the you know thanks Julie
blah blah blah so the only thing if I
were ten maybe I'd be like questioning
whether but I mean as an adult I'm like
yeah I think this is yeah oh yeah yeah
and I mean I would be surprised if she
really does betray Varrick to the point
that she's a bad guy at the end of this
literally
there and then I'm forgetting her name
red shirt
what's her name the father in jail and
everything her father looks like me
assigning Asami Li jailed ho Misaki yeah
I was laughing that's Toby music this is
this is what the creepy cat boss that's
scared so many children and yeah and
there's even a you know it's so funny
those scenes where she's trying to come
to grips with her father I'm like let's
don't seem to connect too much a story
but I'm like I really invested I'm just
like it should have been scenes that
we're back in like season two or three
but but they're we won't start that
again but yeah I mean if ya did
I can't think of a single pretty much
all of these episodes so far I've been
better than the first three seasons put
together I hit that point where I'm like
I'm Way more invested in these first
what are we on Episode five now yeah
first five episodes of this then in any
of the seasons I am like really blown
away by how good this season yes I I
mean everything it's Emmy it's all it's
all building up but it's not to a point
kind of like the last season where it's
like okay everything's just gonna be on
sort of the payoff in terms of thousand
continuation but I mean it's like
because you're seeing stuff happening
and they're good debates and they're
good dialogues and just the just seeing
that army out there I mean you just feel
that tension it's like what are the
rings oh really kind of heavy tense I
I'd argue Searle or the Rings but like a
little bit more politics and I mean not
that where the rings didn't have talking
and it definitely did but a little bit
more like let's come to an agreement
Lord of the Rings because politics is
just do man yeah or or like Game of
Thrones says it really waits for the
action but more movies but yeah and I'm
just really blown away by how good this
season is this I think this was the
first time even though I like horrifying
this is first time an episode where when
they cut to the credit I was like oh
I've been thinking that since literally
it started since episode one every time
it cuts to the credits I'm like Darrent
know the rest of it
no but I was like yes last time maybe
not as much because it was a little bit
of a fluffier episode yeah well every
other episode I've been like oh well I
think you were telling me to going in
you're just like yeah this one like it
because you saw it before me like it
doesn't let up and it does it there's a
few good moments I guess of comedy with
with Varig which I'm all that is great
yeah and comedy comes laced with this
dark abyss yeah yeah that the Varrick
moment was funny where he blows up the
spirit vine but it ends with generals
Elvis strangling him over no egos what's
he doing he's creating the awful weapon
that I like to say I listen to the voice
heads I also like the idea that there's
always sort of this thing in I don't
know anything that talks about spirits
or energy and stuff like that so you
can't magic it just spirits just spirits
I like the fact that they're bringing
technology into it I like the phase
trying to measure and he's trying to
almost you know contain it if it can be
contained you know he's trying to figure
it out no and I like sets that's
something he would Deeks geeks EPS nerds
absolutely love it when you mix
spirituality and technology I mean the
mythic ourian's went over great yeah
right I mean everybody loved that but
you know what I mean like I'm given this
because it seemed to be kind of
introduced gradually whereas Star Wars
is like magic we mentioned
midi-chlorians
yeah the sudden like I'm like where was
that before and that no point to do
whatever well in this world like I said
oh we're like we said very much is it's
like the technology boom has come and
Republic City all that stuff's like
technology plays a really big part I'm
amazed oh I can see them like just
continuing to go and like what else can
we figure out what else can we yeah and
Asami's done her part they were
mentioning in the backstory to build
basically an infrastructure so the city
can function with the spirit worlds
there's this idea that the two are kind
of combined I'm amazed that is sloppy in
my opinion as some of the exposition is
with like
just mentioning and Asami's help rebuilt
the city's infrastructure to make it
match the spirit world and I I'm just
like we never really showed us any of
that like there's a lot of things that
they didn't show and they just sort of
telling you I'm kind of amazed it works
as well as it does yeah like there are
moments that I'm just like this would
piss me off on almost any other show but
they've managed to somehow pull this off
I think it's because you're so invested
in the other stuff going on and they
have so much detail about that and you I
mean like I said this battle being built
up and those armies set up but like
nothing much has really happened if you
look at it I mean she's too quick I'm
gonna take over everything and yeah
she's taking over a lot of towns but
even then it's like in terms of like
being more than rain style battles and
all these armies going and stop it so
we've really seen a very good diplomacy
I keep the funny thing is I mean now-now
kuvira's out of yourself as a bad guy
straight up but still the amount of
restraint and diplomacy in trying to
work the different sides to get her aims
through politics like Cora why don't you
why don't you talk to her you know no we
have to use Bolin to project you know
yes Mart yeah it would have been easy
just to be like and March straight up
yeah but she's a politician ya know you
don't and you still always it's like
even now I kind of have those moments
even though I've seen her gone batshit
nuts where I'm still like I mean she's
like no wait she's great but by me again
that's just that's a great villain ah
and I love you know I was gonna mention
to the way she's the expressions on her
face I mean they're just the perfect I
think a lot of people feel when I want
to look tough I show no emotion and you
just look dead but there is this way
even though there's a balance you know
even just a little bit of that eyebrow a
little bit of a nod and a look to the
left or I mean it's like those little
touches do a lot because I'm not just
writing nature just for acting in
general well this is a very expressive
episode the scene with Asami and her
father any of the scenes with Korra any
of the like I was noticing the facial
expressions in this one and then with
Julie you know if you read her
face when she's talking like it's this
interesting mix of like I think you can
almost tell that maybe she's bluffing a
bit but she's also legitimately pissed
because and she's been getting crap done
in the whole series well particularly
this and her facial reads when she was
angry and being like no spare me take
him I hate him like you know I want to
join you you know you're the smart one
like the look on her face the animation
is just great and it's been that way
this whole episode I also like oh well
okay if I happen to pick one thing it's
a real nitpick I was gonna say the
actual suits like the metal suits they
look a little red versus blue to me
their way you don't mean that CGI no I
mean like we're both now it seemed to
move pretty like you felt the way this
one they they can't move like video game
characters you go there dude but it
which is you know it's played up a touch
for comedy if you were complaining they
are robot I feel like I'm playing an old
game of command & Conquer or something
like yeah but little I like to maybe
move a touch too fast or sup but its
animation I mean like everything else is
really blowing me away
it's a real epic the rest of the
character work in the background design
and everything has been so incredible
this season yeah I don't care I'm like
you know I'll put up with a little bit
of CGI overlay and a gorgeous backdrop
versus the whole thing just looks cheap
I mean there's a scene where you know
someone's sitting down and the camera
just like you know pants to the right a
little bit and it's like animation all
you have to do is have the fiend of
background the person there and with the
background that's it but it's like they
CG just this little tiny bench or
something to like move with it but looks
painted into the background like not
even a second long and it's like man
they're throwing so much effort just in
the smallest things so it's it's so
impressive how much they're gonna say
this to redemption for Bolin
big-time that fight
you know I the the whole peace
negotiation process it was typical goofy
Bolin like whoa
we all just get in a circle hold hands
and sing Kumbaya you know but when he
realizes so Doug and Doug in the middle
of it when kuvera's like well they're my
loyal subjects Bowman we had to send
them to education camps I mean wait are
you disloyal like what are you doing
like maybe I shouldn't have trusted you
at all maybe you need to be sent to
re-education camp and Bolin's like no I
totally believe in you you know yes sir
you know she stares him and Doug's like
ah see to just jumped cut to him going
she's crazy I just had to wait a little
bit yeah I know what happens five
minutes later he'd be made up with very
good just she's great which works
because it was clie it's like if you
don't do that you had to have another
joke and having him and Varrick say it
at the exact same time I thought I was
paranoid how do you know she's crazy
no yeah so Bolin helping them escape and
then that fight was real Redemption like
I took Bolin seriously he fucking kicked
ass you know and really the only misstep
was Varrick himself getting caught
through his own incompetence and that
was the one moment there where I lost
low because when the three of them show
up then and kuvira's office I was like
really really guys you couldn't find a
way out of that well two things come to
mind one is that you know he does have
his head I mean like you just get no
more Varrick but the other thing comes
in my head is that they probably
wouldn't have killed him because they
need them for the weapon I'm wondering
if Julie knew that which is why I'm
wondering if even more this is a plant
you know like maybe he one could be
after a separate I don't think it could
be I'm not sure blends on that though no
I don't think I would have been clever
enough considering the pretty badass
earthbending he was doing in fight
because it was Bolin clearly on his own
he was getting very little help from
Varrick and Zhu Li was occupied with the
other guy so it
he really was kicking major ass I'm like
finally he gets this moment to shine and
then it ends with you know Varrick
getting caught I'm like ah like so I
hope he's got another moment before the
show's over cuz I was like this is the
Boleyn I've kind of wanted to see for a
while where's that alright it's fucking
on well maybe he's always been a pretty
good fighter he's always a pretty good
fighter but he's always had like
help Mako's they're usually this is one
of the first times like Oh Italy was
doing yes must work actually no they
both were doing the work but Julie's not
a bender I'm talking about just pure
about analyzing yeah I mean Bolin's
always had help from from Chora and
macho and like this was a moment where
as a vendor alone I thought Bolan really
got to shine so it was kind of a shame
that it ended like I'm that low note of
white and then into the office but I'll
tell you the way they've written God
Emperor now Zola's role like she is
seriously intimidating when she's like
you're going to re-education camp I'm
like shit I'm kind of really scared for
Bolin I'm like is he gonna come out like
me and cheering kanaday like all hail
our new glorious leader lie I think this
villain honestly might even be better
than honestly Mort and he had mystery
too but I mean there's way more depth to
this villain ya know this is like a
relief and the Bible yeah
Amon at a small revolution this this
woman's got an army like this is not
like a little startup thing this is like
oh she pretty much runs their equivalent
of Asia what and I think what makes the
villain even more interesting it's only
time we've seen villains especially in
cartoon shows and kid shows where they
have a giant army they're like you know
just come on even down to like this
Saruman who's not bad villain but it's
like you know dig them up they're very
basic and like I said the what you said
the diplomacy that she tried that just
the true belief in what she's doing but
there's just still this coldness and
still this harshness that's like no
there's there is no other way and you do
see her born as well when they have that
conversation in the flashback if it's
just I mean it's almost like a
Shakespearean villain it's just a good
good ERISA something Nicholas Meyer was
saying the commentary for a Star Trek -
I I guess he was having trouble getting
Ricardo Montalban to act like he wanted
to in Khan's initial scenes and the
first scenes he's like you know I mean
it was Ricardo bond 20 was good but it
was
it was a little too shabby over the top
you know when he was like talking to
check off or whatever for the first time
and he like went up to me and Nicholas
Meyer apparently said like the secret to
really truly crazy people is they don't
need to shout
except when they only really really need
to otherwise they're so intimidating and
so crazy you just don't need to do it
and that's what kuvera's like the moment
where she held Varrick over the train
tracks or when she you know really goes
up to Bolin and starts questioning his
loyalty is scary because she's not like
that normally so there's this craziness
that's underneath 24/7 and then when it
comes out you're like oh now we've gone
from crazy to really crazy but you also
see how it comes how she comes to that
because yeah just keep so much of it
like you know no I can't Empire I don't
have time for this oh you wanna start
yalda okay I'm just gonna hold you over
that are you gonna tell me yeah I can
tell okay good it's like it's what I'm
so get you know it's so casual yeah well
she's got a lot on her mind you know
maybe I should try this just smells it
it's pretty it's very like Stalinist
like you could just see Stalin doing
something like that oh you didn't like
the portrait of me or you didn't paint a
right Porter be two coulombs away with
you what's next yes a person's got the
world to create and that's crazy about
it it's just like you know that
underneath there just seething 24/7 and
then occasionally it just comes out in
that moment of just like oh yeah I know
you've served me well but to the
reeducation camp yeah and you see how
she's successful what you get I think
it's so important in a show especially
some that sound like a kid's channel you
know that's like oh they're just bad and
oh why didn't we see this bad for that
person is clearly bad and here it's like
no you really see how people warmed up
to her and how they can choose a side
and it really makes sense I think that's
such an important thing to understand
especially when not just you know the
characters see if I mean like the film
world sees it and how could anyone fall
for such an obvious maniac or something
but they really show it and they really
show the progression and you know it
does
happen in real life and everyone's just
like oh can anyone just Hitler's a bag I
couldn't they see them with Hitler and
stuff and there but there was this
progression there was this really
brilliant intelligent he did make way
through the highways work yeah I mean
trains random time so this there you go
but most people are concerned about yeah
I need the whole you know the other
taboo stuff I mean that Hitler is very
underrated I just want to say the line
go on record saying that no no I just
want to have a few longer I say Hitler's
underrated please send all angry emails
care of dog at that guy with the glasses
- I make a Hitler joke in those - your
critic this week so it's like it's been
a Hitler week I've had to look at a
picture of Hitler putting a cookie on
his face so just strange Hitler imagery
is in my mind very simply as Mel Brooks
said it was a funny guy
Wow on that note I'm added myself as a
Nazi and I can't wait for the next
episode when the hero zelda general zona
is gonna win today god Empress Adolf
Zelda Erik Gables